chick Jetta go get busy you'll be next
up you go dominate them keep that back
straight and keep very not quit that
Daddy dominate knock it off okay okay
good okay get up get up there now hurry
come on lift ride but nominated
nominated
I wanted to be a professional Cowboys
from fires I can remember since I was a
little bitty I always wanted to hold
that gold buckle in my hand
my name's pikas Tatum and I'm 10 years
old
father-god thing for this day I think
for all of our friend Simon and he's got
dick for this food Jesus name Amen I won
seven saddles since I was seven
- now I'm ten and thirty-eight buckles
my mom she got to be a world champion
and the team roping in the head and in
2008 that was really cool and my dad
rode Bulls for 13 years he didn't make
it to the national finals ever anymore
and hauled that gold buckle but you just
don't always get to do that
our entire family both on Brett and I
side I've been rodeo cowboys we were
just created to be cowboys and cowgirls
Vegas he chose the same Road that we did
but I don't necessarily know that we
honestly chose it ourselves we chose
this area because we wanted to raise
Pecos as a cowboy and we really felt
like it was still cool to be a cowboy in
Texas we're very blessed with lots of
animals we call it the funny farm around
here we have I think from ten head of
cattle to 35 head of cattle and we can't
forget Pegasus goats he's got a goat
herd that he started when he was a year
old it's a great place to hang our hats
and raise our son
I always been on a horse since far as I
can remember and I can't really remember
the first time I ever did it oh you got
on the horse when he was a baby weasel
yeah the very first time pics was on a
horse he was two weeks old we took him
to a high school rodeo he couldn't even
hold his own head
yay pegas we decided to home-school pay
us halfway through first grade our
theory was we always wanted to raise our
own kid we didn't want to leave him with
anyone else we just kind of always had
that feeling about it that's five times
what is two times two yeah oh we take a
few steps off the door to the classroom
get class taken care of in about four
hours and then wrote all afternoon every
day about 3:30 4:00 I practice and to
make it better so I can be a world
champion someday you gotta want to go
get it and have to go get it and I
really want to be one sometimes he
worries me because he is so adult like
kind of populist sometimes that's a good
thing sometimes that's a bad thing we
you know we can't really guide him in
that direction because that's who he is
you believe really care
this weekend he'll be going to the Texas
High School Rodeo Association we're
through the halfway point of the season
in Vegas I think right now is leading
all our own standings there's not a lot
of room for stub in your toes because
there's not a lot of the rodeos and if
your goal is to win every event and then
everybody is important sometimes it's
hard being a cowboy we just tried to
train them in the right ways rodeo is
very dangerous sport anything around
animals is a dangerous sport you just
have no control over some of the things
that they do
you got a lot of chances to get hurt
especially kind of step off and you
might step from my attorney steer run
you over take you step on you
throw you up in the air I usually don't
slow down the think of that
we tried to teach him and we've always
tried to teach him how to ride correctly
and how to be in control of his animal
because they're an animal we rodeo about
every weekend this weekend he gets on
two steers and he needed to just make
sure he's in tune a little bit and make
sure that he practices you're stopping
halfway through stare I didn't stolen I
feel like I get butterflies in but if
you use it in the right way you can make
good out of it so in the steer I didn't
pick I see is taking a little break and
it's been about two months since he's
been on any steers stair job take me and
then it kicked my ankle and rolled it in
the dirt to me it looked like I broke
his ankle the way it just stepped on it
sideways like that
I got him some ice and he put it on
there he finished his events off that
day he had a little bit of black and
blue in there but it wasn't that bad of
an injury he ready okay
Hey look slowly all the way back over
Lucky's ooh and throw your body like
this and then you'll be facing that way
don't get off next to a little kick you
like they did that yes exactly
you wanna rub calves yeah okay then you
gotta get off your steers good
yeah there you go that's what I'm
talking about give me five I don't care
if you didn't land you're still going
that way
it don't matter you see what I'm saying
that's right my favorite event is tie
don't open it's just cuz it's such a
rush and I always liked it since I was a
little bitty go back him up square him
up square them up move them over
I am a worrywart I don't like to watch a
lot of the things that happen first
I like Brett to go take him because I
would make pecos afraid you're ready to
rub some pekus
your gentleman just going that's the
reason why my dad like bore died his
eternal one went crazy and that's how
mine goes in the capital
you're strong come on their car there
you go come on
we tried to really practice at our house
just like we're gonna rope with the
rodeos or ride a thread yes yeah yeah
that metal bar like the video speaks out
why on screen yeah cuz he never pull it
in your day yeah I mean you hit on the
dummy I say alright I kiss up my kit
folder okay and since your Pony key yes
when he was small I think some people
thought that we pushed him to do it but
he's pushed us he's made us better at
what we do because his 1/2 of it and he
gets us out there more there's days that
pretty tired after work and I'd like to
maybe just relax one day but then I know
I mean Pegasus tan he's only gonna be at
home eight more years I better spend
every second I can with him ride the
physician cape a kiss watch the feet
when you leave here
and being a cowboy it's it's a must it's
not a maybe you're a what if it's a must
it's the best feeling ever to watch him
do something that he hadn't been able to
do before when you actually see him do
what you told him to do it's like oh
thank you Jesus you got this
this weekend we're going up to Fort
Worth to compete in some rodeos offlane
do some good there we usually try to say
a prayer before every time that we
compete we pray for ourselves and our
animals your odds are very very low when
you get 30 you have an animal that
you're on an animal that you're trying
to catch or an animal you're trying to
ride your odds are very slim
we don't expect take us to win every
time he go somewhere he's just like
everyone else you just kind of feel like
they need I didn't get it done I could
have done it but I just didn't do it
if you're blessed to have a great rodeo
great if not you have to learn how to
rebound from it the losing factor is
what we call it when you come home and
you're not the champion you want to work
so much harder because he knows that's
the only way that you're going to get
better
this weekend's rodeo if he wants to win
in the year-end it's important today the
rodeo it's for high school junior high
and first the fifth grade is youth and
um be a news they don't compete at the
state or national level but they get to
compete at the regional level against
other kids 1st through 5th grade
pick a sword I'd steer till team rope
he'll do some tie-down roping some
breakaway rope and he's in the top three
in every standings and he's first him
all around so he needs to just go have a
consistent rodeo and have lots of fun
and he should stay where he's at in the
standings okay
gear up stop don't sure they're being
useless no weak okay when he's driving I
was just numb I think I this video and
then wait for this hey I think you won
the first go I'm a good read
perfect sat up there just need to work
on looking over your shoulder and
getting off just a little bit better on
this next one and dominate the next one
next we'll be breakaway you're open and
then go time and you're numb done have
fun push on the steps and be aggressive
yes wait yeah I want to make my mom and
dad proud of me just too good Oprah
let's go tiny might stumble or your rope
might go under your horse's chest and
then they get all crazy and then like
they flip over and and just all kinds of
things happen yep you
let it open for business
monitor give necks
your adrenaline zone when you make a
good run and sponge people there you
like yeah I made a good run it gives me
more of a drive to want to go get it
harder don't want to go win more come on
step out step out yeah perfect
you know he really is a great cowboy not
just because he's mine and Brett's child
he puts his heart into it and if peak
has decided tomorrow that he didn't want
to be a cowboy and he wanted to play
basketball we would be his number one
fans
on the way home he's already planning
and going we gonna get home in time
where I can go out there and rope today
we're like no and tomorrow you're going
to take the day off - no I can't I need
to get out there and practice
rodeo is not a sport to me it's a
lifestyle it evolved from real cowboys
as we call them and I feel like we
really need to be true to our roots and
remember that it's something real
special to be a cowboy
the best achievement ever is a gold
buckle holding those gold buckles not a
lot of people have them hopefully
someday as I told one of those gold
buckles in my hand and caught him
you